BEGIN THE HEARING TODAY.
.
WE WILL.
KNOCKED OUT OBVIOUSLY TAKE ANY
ACTIONS WE HAD PLENTY CAN
ACTIONS ANYWAY BUT WILL OPEN
THEY'VE A HEARING OFFICIALLY
WHEN WE GET ANOTHER MEMBER HERE
TO TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BUT WE
CAN BEGIN WITH INFORMATIONAL
PIECE SINCE WE KNOW WE'RE ON A
VERY SHORT SCHEDULE TODAY. AND.
WE ARE WILL HAVE TO BE BACK IN
SESSION IN ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
MINUTES.
OF WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES PRESENTATION SO WE
WANNA TRY TO GET. AS MUCH DONE
AS POSSIBLE IF NOT ALL OF THE
ITEMS DONE.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL.
.
THE.
INDIVIDUALS FORWARD WITH GOING
TO BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO
BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
ITEM THAT IS THE LEAST
CONTROVERSIAL.
AND.
.
TWO THROUGH SIXTEEN ALL OF THOSE
ITEMS HAVE TO DO IT REPAIRS THAT
HAVE BEEN MANDATE IT.
BECAUSE OF LOVE PROBLEMS VOTE
WHETHER VARIOUS OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS AND SO WE WANT TO.
A MAKE SURE ALL THOSE ITEMS ARE
ARE THERE THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PROM IT'S IT CAN
ITEM NUMBER ONE SEEMS ONE THAT
HAS A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONTROVERSY. WE NOT APPOINT
SOMEONE ASKED ABOUT TO. CHECK
THAT HAVE THE ROLL CALL.
WEBER HERE.
JONES SAWYER PRESIDENT
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE.
OKAY GREAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISH ITSELF. I'VE INFORMED
EVEN FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS THE
ARE TO REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES.
EITHER BY PHONE AS WELL AS IN
PERSON THAT WE HAD A MEETING
TODAY SO THEY ARE AWARE OF THE
TWO THIRTY MEETING. ON.
SO WILL BEGIN WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER TWO TWO THROUGH SIXTY YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
.
MEMBERS SO.
IN THE INTEREST OF GETTING
THROUGH THIS AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE.
I'M GOING TO JUST BRIEFLY LAY
OUT HIGH LEVEL THE DOLLARS IN
POSITIONS INVOLVED WITH THESE
PROPOSALS AND THEN. HAVE MY
PROGRAM SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
GO INTO THE DETAILS.
SO WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE'RE
ASKING FOR SIXTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR
TO REPLACE THE ROOFS AT THREE OF
OUR FACILITIES INCLUDING ONE
JUVENILE FACILITY. AND
ADDITIONALLY WERE ASKING FOR
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR SOME
MOLD REMEDIATION EFFORTS.
THIS DOES HAVE A BUDGET ARE
PLUS ONE COMPONENT OF ABOUT
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
REFER PLACEMENTS AT TWO MORE
FACILITIES. I'M JOINED BY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DEAN BOARD OF OUR
FACILITIES PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
AND MANAGEMENT DIVISION. HE'S
GOING TO TELL YOU JUST A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT IT BUT THE PROPOSED ON
THEM WHEN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DEAN BORG REPRESENTING
THE FACILITY PLANNING THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT DIVISION
FOR CDC ARE.
AS.
MISTER LOPEZ SAID.
YOU I WON'T GO OVER THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS AGAIN ILLITERATE ADDRESS
ABOUT A HUNDRED SIXTY BUILDINGS
AT THESE FIVE FACILITIES OVER
THE TWO YEARS. IT EXPANDS ON THE
A ROOF REPLACEMENT FUNDING THAT
WAS APPROVED IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT WHERE THAT
JUST FOCUS PRIMARILY ON VERY.
SIGNIFICANT BUILDINGS THAT
SIGNIFICANT WATER LEAKS.
RATHER THAN JUST ADDRESS THOSE
BUILDINGS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
HERE'S MORE COMPREHENSIVE
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM.
GET SIMPLY TAKING YOUR OF ALL
OF THE BUILDINGS AT A PRISON
THAT HAVE SIMILARLY SITUATED
GROUPS HAVE THEY ALL HAVE TWENTY
YEAR OLD SINGLE PLY ROOFS. MAY
BE.
HALF OF THEM ARE LEAKING RIGHT
NOW THE OTHER HALF A POLYGON
LEAK IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WE'RE GONNA REPLACE ALL OF THEM
AT ONE TIME SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO BACK LATER. AND HAVE
ANY FURTHER INTERRUPTIONS A
PROGRAM FEEDING HOUSING MEDICAL
CARE EXCEPT RA. WE'RE GONNA
PERFORM THIS WITH THE INMATE
WARD LABOR PROGRAM AND.
JUST ONE LAST FACT THE FIVE
FACILITIES WERE GONNA REPLACE
ROOF SAID CURRENTLY HOUSE ABOUT
SIXTEEN THOUSAND.
INMATES AND WARD SO THAT'S A
NUMBER OF BET INMATES OF A
BENEFIT.
ONCE LEAD THESE REPLACEMENTS
ARE DONE
OKAY. THINK COMMENTS FINANCE
ILIO.
ANY MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
THREE EXCUSE ME.
ALRIGHT.
THIS.
ITEM REQUEST SO ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY IN ORDER TO PAY
FOR A A ONE TIME SPECIAL
ASSESSMENT FOR A LEVY REPAIRS
DOWN IN A. AT THE TWO FACILITIES
NEAR CORCORAN THERE'S A LEVY
THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE.
PRISONS BEING CONSTRUCTED THAT
PROTECTS THE AREA WHERE THE
PRISONS ARE LOCATED.
THE LEVEE DISTRICT FOUND.
SUBSIDENCE IN THEIR LEVEES LAST
YEAR AND SO THEY WENT TO AN
EMERGENCY PROGRAM OF RAISING
THEM UPWARDS OF TWO FEET IN
CERTAIN AREAS TO ADDRESS THE
SUBSIDENCE.
THEY WENT THROUGH THE PROP TWO
EIGHTEEN PROCESS TO ASSESS THE
VALUE OF THE SPECIAL BENEFIT AND
HOW TO ASSESS AT AGAINST THE
LANDOWNERS AND ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IS THE.
ASSESSMENT OF FOR CDC
OKAY MANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
ELIO.
ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
IT HAVE COMMENTS AT THE AT THE
END OF THOSE TWO THROUGH SIXTEEN
FROM THE PUBLIC IF ANYONE HAS
ANY COMMENTS ON ANY OF THE TO
FOOD ITEMS TWO THROUGH SIXTY.
OKAY I IMPORT OKAY ITEM FOUR IS.
AT THE DUAL VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION I REQUEST TWO POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
WORKING DRAWINGS THE SECOND
PHASE OF DESIGN.
AT THIS PRISON OUR WATER
TREATMENT PLANT WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT HAVE TO WORK IN
CONCERT.
IN ORDER TO REMOVE.
MIGHT REMOVE ITEMS.
THE WATER THAT WE GET OUT OF
THE GROUND AS TO ACTUALLY BE
CLEANER WHEN WE PUT IT DIED
DISPOSE OF IT INTO THE DELTA.
ARE BRIAN CONCENTRATOR SYSTEM
HAS.
BEEN UNRELIABLE LEADING TO OF
FINES AND.
VIOLATIONS OF OUR OF THE WASTE
WATER TREATMENT ESPECIALLY WE'RE
GONNA REPLACE IT WITH A SYSTEM
THAT IS LESS COMPLICATED AND
ALLOWS FOR MAINTENANCE WITHOUT
HAVING TO TAKE DOWN THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM WHICH IS ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE RIGHT NOW.
OKAY.
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE WELL
OILED.
MEMBERS.
YOU HAVE A BOOK TO SAYS I CAN'T
BUDGET.
ONE KNOW WHAT'S IN THERE. THEM.
OKAY. ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
I THINK YOU A BIT THE A PELICAN
BAY STATE PRISON US AT ONE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF A YARD.
FACILITY DE I PLAY BROKEN BAY
USED TO BE A SECURITY HOUSING
UNIT WAS CONVERTED LAST YEAR TO
A LEVEL TWO FACILITY AND SO WE
NEED A YARD FOR THE INMATES TO
HAVE THEIR JUST LIKE THEY WOULD
HAVE IT ANY OTHER LEVEL TO
FACILITY.
BASICALLY.
OUT WALKING TRACK MULTIPURPOSE
FIELD BASKETBALL HANDBALL ON IN
MAY RELIGIOUS A YARDS.
AS I SAID THIS WAS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION AND THIS ONE WILL
BE CONSTRUCTED USING THE INMATE
WARD LABOR PROGRAM.
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE ELIO.
MEMBER COMMENTS.
JEFF MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX OKAY. OF THIS IS ALSO IT A
PELICAN BAY.
THIS IS ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WORKING DRAWINGS ARE
THE SECOND PHASE OF DESIGN.
ARE EIGHT LEVEL FOR HOUSING
UNITS AT PELICAN BAY NOT THE
SHOE BUT THE LEVEL FOR HOUSING
UNITS.
WERE CONSTRUCTED IN THE LATE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES WITHOUT FIRE
SPRINKLERS AND OTHERS CAME TO
THE ATTENTION OF THE US STATE
FIRE MARSHAL RECENTLY AND.
GOING BACK THROUGH OUR RECORDS
IN THEIR RECORDS COULDN'T FIND
ANY RECORD OF AGREEMENTS OR OVER
APPROVALS TO.
DO AND WITHOUT FIRE SPRINKLERS
SO THIS.
IS THIS SECOND PHASE THE DESIGN
IN ORDER TO INSTALL FIRE
SPRINKLERS AND THE SUPPORTING A
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE OF FOR THAT
PROJECT.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
ELLIOTT.
ANY MEMBER COMMENTS.
OKAY MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. ALRIGHT ITEM SEVEN.
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL CENTER
THAT'S UP ON THE SUSANVILLE
AREA.
WE'RE GONNA REPLACE A TO
KITCHEN AND DINING A FACILITIES
ARE UP THERE THIS IS NINETEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CONSTRUCTION. OF CONSTRUCTION
WAS ORIGINALLY FUNDED IN THE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN BUDGET FOR
THIS PROJECT WHEN WE WENT OUT TO
BID LAST SUMMER WE FOUND THAT WE
COULD NOT GET A LOT OF THE
INTEREST FROM A GENERAL
CONTRACTORS.
ENDED UP ONLY RECEIVING TWO
BIDS WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF INTERESTED BIDDERS YOUR BID
STILL COME IN VERY WELL AND IN A
ADDITIONAL REVIEW WE IDENTIFIED
ESTIMATES.
OUR ORIGINAL ESTIMATE HAD
UNDERSTATED CERTAIN COST IN
QUANTITIES SO THIS REQUEST FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS MORE
THAN WHAT THE APPROPRIATION AND
SIXTEEN SEVEN SEVENTEEN HAD
BEEN.
THE COMMENTS.
ONE IS A LOYAL MEMBER.
OKAY MOVING ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
OKAY.
THINK WEDNESDAY PRISON A NEW
BOILER FACILITY ASSUME
REQUESTING TWENTY POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE. OUR EXISTING
BOILERS NOT MEET EMISSION
STANDARDS AND WE.
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING HERE ALSO
BUT.
BEFORE GOING OUT TO BID ARE A
CONSULTANT IDENTIFIED NEW BOILER
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO REPLACE THE EXISTING BOILERS
WITH ONES THAT REQUIRED A
SMALLER BUILDING AND WOULD BE
LESS EXPENSIVE ON GOING TO
OPERATE SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF FINALIZING THE REDESIGN.
FOR THIS.
INTO FOR THIS PROJECT AND THIS
WILL BE THE CONSTRUCTION FUNDING
TO GO OUT TO BID.
OKAY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE ILIO.
MEMBERS.
OKAY MOVING ON ITEM NUMBER NINE.
NOT ITEM NINE A CORRECTIONAL
TRAINING FACILITY THAT'S OF ONE
OF THE PRISONS DOWN IN THE SOUL
IN AN AREA.
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A CELL DOOR RETROFIT
THIS'LL TAKE A AND MYSTERY OF
SEGREGATION UNIT.
WHERE WE HAVE CURRENTLY BARRED
CELL FRONTS AND REPLACE HIM WITH
A SOLID SELF FRONT?
THAT ALLOWS MORE PROTECTION FOR
STAFF AND INMATES WERE BEING
ESCORTED IN FRONT OF THE OF
CELLS AND REDUCES ANY.
SUICIDE RISK THAT EXISTS A FROM
THE BARD OPEN SELF FRONTS.
WITH THIS IS A ONGOING PROJECT
THAT WE'VE DONE AT OTHER PRISONS
IS CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION
AT TED DVI RIGHT NOW IN A
SIMILAR TYPE UNIT.
OKAY. COMMENTS.
THEY COME WITH MEMBERS.
IMPROVING ON DIED OF NUMBER TEN.
I AM TEN IS A MINOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY A PROGRAM WE HAVE ONE
PROJECT THEIR SIX HUNDRED NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AT PELICAN BAY STATE PRISON TO
CONSTRUCT A THIRTEEN HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT WALK IN FREEZER.
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO.
PURCHASE FOOD IN THE LARGER
BULK QUANTITIES AND WERE ABLE TO
DO RIGHT NOW BASED UPON THE
FREEZER CAPABILITY.
THE PELICAN BAY HAS THE HIGHEST
PER UNIT COST FOR FOOD.
ACROSS OUR PRISONS.
BY ALLOWING FOR MORE BOOK
PURCHASES THEY'VE ESTIMATED THAT
IN ABOUT SIX TO SEVEN YEARS
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO SAVE MONEY
ENOUGH MONEY TO COVER YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD EQUAL THE COST OF
BUILDING THIS ADDITIONAL FREEZE.
OKAY.
THE COMMENTS.
INCOME FOR MEMBERS.
MOVING ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
ITEM ELEVEN.
STATEWIDE BUDGET PACKAGES IN
ADVANCE PLANNING.
THIS.
FUNDING ALLOWS US TO.
TAKE THE.
THE CONCEPT THAT COME FROM
PRISONS.
FOR THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
CONSTRUCTED OR RENOVATED AND TO
TAKE THOSE AND PROVIDE MORE AYE
IF FLESH AMOUNTS OF THAT THEIR
WELL DEVELOPED PROPOSALS BEFORE
WE BRING THEM TO COMMITTEE OF
BEING ABLE TO DO BETTER BUDGET
ESTIMATION AND SCHEDULE
ESTIMATION.
NO COMMENT FROM EITHER SIDE.
OKAY APPROVAL ON ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE.
ALL RIGHT.
BACK UP TO A PELICAN BAY STATE
PRISON.
THIS IS ALSO IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THE.
CONVERSION OF FACILITY DE FROM
SHOE TO GENERAL POPULATION LEVEL
TO INMATE THERE'S AN EXISTING
STORAGE ROOM AND THIS REQUEST A
MILLION DOLLARS.
TO RENOVATE THIS EXISTING
STORAGE ROOM TO PROVIDE THREE
CLASSROOMS.
SO THAT THESE LEVEL TWO INMATES
CAN HAVE A PLACE FOR.
FOR REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING.
CURRENTLY THEY'RE USING
TEMPORARY DIVIDERS TO DIVIDED
INTO TWO CLASSROOMS BUT IT'S
STILL VERY NOISY AND NOT
CONDUCIVE TO THE.
TO THE LEARNING PROCESS OKAY
THE COMMENTS FROM FINANCE ILIO.
MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN ITEM THIRTEEN.
THAT'S ALSO ANOTHER CLASSROOM
PROJECT SO AS THE COMMITTEE
KNOWS WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
EXPANSION OF OUR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND IN MOST OF OUR
PRISONS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT WITHIN EXISTING
SPACE.
AYE ISSUE THIRTEEN AND ISSUE
FOURTEEN ARE TWO PLACES WHERE AN
ADDITIONAL SPACES CA IS NEEDED.
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO.
SINCE WAS BUILT NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF.
CHANGES OF MISSION A LOT OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMMING THERE
AND SO PROGRAM SPACE WAS
AVAILABLE IN THE ORIGINAL
CONSTRUCTION. NOT AVAILABLE NOW
FOR OUR OF COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. SO THIS
WOULD REQUEST FOREIGN FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BEGIN THE
DESIGN PROCESS PRELIMINARY PLAN
PROCESS TO BUILD THREE.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT CLASSROOM BUILDINGS
ON EACH ART.
ANY COMMENTS.
COMMENTS FORM.
SPENT THE MEMBERS.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN THE
ITEM FOURTEEN.
AT SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON
THAT'S ALSO A TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BEGIN
THE DESIGN PROCESS FOR
ADDITIONAL CLASSROOM SPACE AT
THIS LOCATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE
CLASSROOMS GOING ON IN THE GYM.
IT'S A OLDER STYLE PRISON JIM
LIKE TEN THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT OF
JIM JIM SPACE.
TEMPER DIVIDERS ARE REALLY NOT
WORKING VERY WELL SO THIS WILL
ALLOW US TO REMODEL EIGHT
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET.
UNDER UTILIZED SPACE IN ANOTHER
BUILDING TO PROVIDE THE
CLASSROOMS FOR.
BOTH CBT AND THE LONG TERM
OFFENDER PROGRAMS
CAN YOU COMMENT.
COMMENCEMENT I'D NUMBER FIFTEEN
OKAY.
A ITEM FIFTEEN IS NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
BEGIN THE DESIGN PROCESS A
PRELIMINARY PLAN PROCESS AT
CALIFORNIANS TUITION FOR MEN
DOWN IN CHINO.
ONE OF THE YARDS THEIR FACILITY
A HAS EIGHT HOUSING UNITS ARE
CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO THAT HAVE HEATING AND
VENTILATION ONLY.
THIS IS.
IN THIS YARD HAS A FAIRLY
UNIQUE.
INMATE POPULATION ABOUT SEVENTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE INMATES ARE
HIGH RISK MEDICAL INMATES ON
THIS ONE YARD A LARGE NUMBER OF
DIABETICS AND.
BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY AND ONE
REASON WHY THEY'RE ALL THERE IS
BECAUSE IT'S A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN RECRUIT.
CLINICIANS TO PROVIDE THE A
CARE WE ALSO HAVE A FOCUSED LOT
OF OUR TRANS GENDER PROGRAMMING
ON THIS YARD BECAUSE OF PRISON
CULTURE. SO THIS IS A PROJECT
WILL BE TO PROVIDE COOLING AYE
IN THE EIGHT HOUSING UNITS ON
THE SHORE.
ANY COMMENTS.
COMMENCEMENT AND MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN. CURRENT
LAST ITEM OF THIS IS THE REAL
PREPARATION OF A CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING OF THAT WAS APPROVED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO TO.
REPLACE US CENTRAL KITCHEN AT
THE CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY IN
THEIR WEST FACILITY IT.
TAKES AN EXISTING BUILDING
WHERE THERE'S BOTH CENTRAL
KITCHEN INTO DINERS AND WILL
BUILD.
THREE SEPARATE BUILDINGS TO
REPLACE THAT CENTRAL KITCHEN AND
THEN TO DINER SO THAT THE
INMATES CAN DINE IN THERE
HOUSING AREAS RATHER THAN HAVING
TO CONGREGATE IN THE SAME PLACE.
WE NEED THE REAPPROPRIATION AND
ORDERED KEEPING CONVERTS
AVAILABILITY BE ON JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CURRENTLY PROJECTING TO
COMPLETING THIS PROJECT AND NOT
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE COMMENTS.
COME SO KICK FUND THAT'S ITEMS
TWO THROUGH SIXTEEN THEY'LL ALL
BE HELD OVER A ARE THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ANY OF.
FOR ARE EITHER I ANY ITEM TWO
THROUGH SIXTEEN ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
THE PROS OR CONS.
RIGHT THANK YOU THEN THAT TAKES
US BACK ITEM NUMBER ONE THE
VENTURA TRAINING CENTER
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WEBER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN TIM
LOT DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE.
NOT WITH ME TODAY ARE MY
PARTNERS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
IN THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS WHO WE'VE BEEN IN A LONG
STANDING PARTNERSHIP WITH A.
OVER THE DECADE SUPPORTING A
CRUISE FOR FIRE FIGHTING AROUND
THE STATE AS WELL AS
CONSERVATION WORK.
TO ADDRESS THAT THE CRITICAL
FUELS IN FORCE MANAGEMENT A
ACTIVITIES NEEDED AROUND THE
STATE WERE BEFORE YOU TODAY FOR
A PROPOSAL. OFFER AN ENHANCED
FIREFIGHTER TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
WHAT'S PROPOSED IS THAT RE
PURPOSING THE EXISTING VENTURA
CONSERVATION CAMP NEAR CAMERINO.
UP INTO AN ENHANCED FIREFIGHTER
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM.
ULTIMATELY UP TO EIGHTY
PARTICIPANTS WOULD BE SELECTED
FOR THIS PROGRAM AND BEGIN AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH.
PROCESS OF TRAINING EDUCATION
ARE TO GET BUT RECEIVE TRAINING
BEYOND JUST OF THE OF THE OF
HAND CREW WILDLAND FIREFIGHTING
SKILL SET. UP BUT ALSO AT MORE
ADVANCED.
FIRE FIGHTING FIGHTING AND FIRE
SERVICE TRAINING SUCH AS THE.
FIRE MARSHAL A FIREFIGHTER ONE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
BUT ULTIMATELY THESE
PARTICIPANTS AFTER THE SIX
MONTHS OF TRAINING AND EDUCATION
WILL PROVIDE TWELVE MONTHS A ON
THE GROUND OF A FIRE CREW. AND
CONSERVATION WORK OPTICALLY
ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST ARE AND
IN THE VENTURA COUNTY AREA BUT
CERTAINLY BE AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND OF STATEWIDE. WELL AS A
FIRE CREW OUT ONCE COMPLETION OF
THE EIGHTEEN MONTHS THESE
OPERATIVES DEPENDS WILL. BE
ELIGIBLE TO COMPETE FOR.
FIREFIGHTING JOBS AROUND
CALIFORNIA WELL IT'S UNDERSTOOD
THAT MANY OF FIRE DEPARTMENTS
AROUND CALIFORNIA REQUIRE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIAN
CERTIFICATION WHICH DOES REQUIRE
A BACKGROUND CHECK.
HELLFIRE AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WHILE IT'S A DESIRED
QUALIFICATION A HIGHER QUALITY
AND USE IT AS A DESIRED
QUALIFICATION THEN IT'S NOT A
REQUIRED.
ELEMENT OF THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS.
BUT CAL FIRE WILL WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO SELECT PARTICIPANTS FOR THIS
PROGRAM. ARE DIRECTLY FROM OUR
EXISTING CONSERVATION CAN'T
PROGRAMS OF THESE WILL BE A
SUCCESSFUL INMATE FIREFIGHTERS
WHO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY. OUT LEFT
THAT PROGRAM AND ARE ARE BEING
RECOMMENDED BY BOTH A
DEPARTMENTS.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THE.
THE EX OFFENDER PORTION OF THIS
PROGRAM OTHER IS ALSO A SPACE
AVAILABLE AND IS IT ENCOURAGED
TO HAVE UP TO TWENTY CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS A PROGRAM
MEMBERS ABBY PART OF THIS
PROGRAM AND TRAIN.
AT THE SAME TIME TO RECEIVE
BENEFIT FROM.
THIS ADVANCED TRAINING AGAIN TO
PROVIDE OF SKILL SET BACK AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS NOT ONLY AT CAL FIRE
FOR LONG STANDING CAREERS BUT
FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS ARE AROUND
CALIFORNIA.
THAT ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU ARE CHECK WEBER AND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BROUGH
PSYCHO OR DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS THE ROLE OF
THE CCC WILL BE TO HIRE THE.
TRAINEES.
WHETHER INITIALLY THERE ARE
PROBABLY TWENTY THIS FALL BUT
EVENTUALLY.
EIGHTY WOULD STAFF THAT TERM
CONSERVATION CAP INVENTOR.
AND BY HIRING THAT WOULD
INCLUDE.
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYROLL FOR.
.
I HEALTH BENEFITS AND ANY OTHER
RELATED HIM RESOURCES ON ISSUES.
ARM IN ADDITION.
CHIEF PROMOTE MENTIONED WE
WOULD HAVE TRAINEES CURRENT.
.
ARE.
TYPICAL.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD O. ADULT COURT MEMBERS.
THAT ARE NOW ARE IT THREE FIRE
CENTERS.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE.
AT BUTTE AT OUR PLASTER CENTER
AND OUR CAMERA SET OF THOSE
THOSE CORE MEMBERS WOULD GO
THROUGH THE. AND CAL FAR
TRAINING.
BASIC FIREFIGHTING TRAINING AND
OTHER RELATED FAR SCIENCE FIRE
TRAINING.
OF COURSE ISN'T CURRICULUM AT
THAT VENTURA CAMP.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY POWERS
DIRECTOR OF FIVE.
DAPPLE
I JUST WANNA MAKE A COUPLE OF
BRIEF COMMENTS ABOUT SOME OF
THE.
.
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
FORWARDED TO US REGARDING THE
POPULATION CHARACTERISTICS AND.
AND THE OVERALL PROGRAM. ARMED
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
OBSERVATIONS ARE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WAS THAT.
.
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE SERVING LOW
RISK NOBLE LOW RISK LOW NEED.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD BEEN
RELEASED.
AND OR ON PAROLE I HAVE MY
STAFF GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE.
AT THE RELEASE YA
CHARACTERISTICS OF THIS
POPULATION AND WE RELEASED A
THOUSAND AND SEVENTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN JULY AND
DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN FROM
THE UP THE CAMP PROGRAM.
FORTY PART FORTY TWO PERCENT UP
POPULATION WAS HIGH RISK.
IF YOU ADD IN THE MODERATE RISK
YOU HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF WHO ARE EITHER MODERATE TO
HIGH RISK.
TO RE OFFEND.
ADDITIONALLY.
THIRTEEN ONLY THIRTEEN PERCENT
OF THE POPULATION HAD EITHER A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR GED.
SO I THINK THAT TIME ABOUT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THIS POPULATION IT
CERTAINLY POPULATION THAT HAS.
BUT.
F. FAIRLY HIGH.
NEED FOR STABLE HOUSING FOR
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT ARE IN
LACKEY NAT THEIR RECIDIVISM RATE
CERTAINLY DOM. WOULD BE RIGHT UP
THERE WITHOUT WITH OUR GENERAL
POPULATION.
THE OTHER SORT OF.
FEEDBACK WE'VE GOT IS THAT THIS
PROGRAMS OUT AN EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAM.
WILL THERE ISN'T ANOTHER
PROGRAM LIKE IT'S FOR US TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
REPLICATED ELSEWHERE.
MOST PROGRAMS DON'T START OUT
AS EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS BOMB
BUT WHAT I CAN ASSURE YOU IS
THAT WHEN WE DO THE CONTRACT FOR
THE COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDER.
THEY WILL USED EVIDENCE THEY
WILL USE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES IN THEIR COUNSELING
PROGRAMS AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
AND CERTAINLY WE DO KNOW THAT
PROVIDING HOUSING PROVIDING JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND GETTING
PAROLEES ARE EMPLOYED. REDUCES
THE RISK TO OFFEND WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY AN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE.
SO I'M. A A I WOULD SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW THE ENEMY FIRE FIRE
PROGRAM THAT CDC ARE AND CAL
FIRE HIS.
HAS HAS BEEN OPERATING FOR
YEARS IS PROBLY ONE OF THE BEST
DEALS IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND WE CERTAINLY SEE THIS I SEE
THIS AS A. AS AS PART OF THAT
CONTINUUM AND.
I THINK INVESTING IN IN THESE
PAROLEES WHO'VE.
HERE'S IN OUR IN OUR INMATE
CAMPS TO COME OUT AND BE GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME. A CCC
GRADUATE AND BECOME A
FIREFIGHTER OR BECOME SOME OTHER
PROFESSION THAT THEY GOT THE THE
TRAINING FOR. IS CERTAINLY A
WORTHWHILE ENDEAVOR ARE IN AND I
WOULD CALL THAT EVIDENCE BASED
EVERYDAY. THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
BELIAU.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CALEDONIA WITH THE LA SHOW WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE PROPOSAL
PRIMARILY BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S
UNLIKELY TO BE COST EFFECTIVE AT
REDUCING RECIDIVISM WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS CITED AS ITS
PRIMARY GOAL. FOR THE PROPOSAL.
WE THINK IT'S NOT LIKELY TO BE
EFFECTIVE FOR THREE REASONS
FIRST IT'S NOT EVIDENCE BASE
THAT IS THERE WERE NOT AWARE OF
SIMILAR PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
FOUND FOUND TO BE WRITTEN
EFFECTIVE. I'M AT REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND THERE'S ALSO NO
PLAN TO FOR A. REBUT INDEPENDENT
OR RIGOROUS ENOUGH EVALUATION TO
ASSESS WHETHER THE PROGRAM IS
INDEED EFFECTIVE ONCE IT'S
IMPLEMENTED.
SECOND IT'S TARGETED I PAROLEES
TO PEOPLE WHO APPEAR TO BE.
AMONG THE LEAST LIKELY TO NEED
SERVICES IN CDC ARE A. AND THIS
IS BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLANNING TO RECRUIT PRIMARILY
INMATE FIREFIGHTERS AS YOU'VE
HEARD.
WHICH IS A POPULATION THAT IS
BELIEVED GENERALLY TO BE OF LOW
RISK TO THE COMMUNITY AND HAS
DEMONSTRATED A WILLINGNESS AND
ABILITY TO WORK.
I THROUGH THE FIRE THEIR
ASSIGNMENT TO THE FIRE CAMP HOW
AND YOU HEARD SOME STATISTICS
JUST NOW I AM I THINK THE KEY
THING TO NOTE IS.
HOW THEY COMPARE HOW THE?
FIRE CAMP POPULATION WOULD
COMPARE TO THEM E. THE REMAINDER
OF THE PAROLEES AS FAR AS THEIR
THEIR RISK IN NEEDS.
.
AND IT'S AN ADDITIONALLY IT'S
THE ADMINISTRATION HASN'T
PROVIDED AT PLAN AS TO HOW THEY
WOULD TARGET. BUT I AM.
INDETERMINATE BEAST OF THE
PROPOSED SERVICES TOWARD
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED NEED NOT JUST RISK OF
RECIDIVISM BUT NEED FOR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES SPECIFICALLY
OR HOUSING ETCETERA THAT THE
PROGRAM WOULD. POTENTIALLY
PROVIDE.
IN OTHER WORDS THE
ADMINISTRATION IT APPEARS IS
PLANNING TO TARGET THE PROGRAM
TO PAROLEES WHO LIKELY HAVE LESS
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT SO TO SPEAK
RELATIVE TO. THE GENERAL PEARLY
POPULATION.
OR TO OTHER POTENTIALLY MORE
HIGH RISK PAROLEES OUT THERE.
AND THIRD IT APPEARS UNLIKELY TO
LEAD TO EMPLOYMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T DONE THE
LABOR MARKET ANALYSIS.
FOR POTENTIAL TO DETERMINE THE
POTENTIAL DEMAND FOR GRAD.
GRADUATES OF THE PROGRAM. AND
IN THE ABSENCE OF SUCH AN
ANNOUNCES WE'VE TURNED TO
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE WHICH SUGGEST
THAT THE MARKET FOR FIREFIGHTERS
IS VERY COMPETITIVE AND THAT
THERE ARE SOME SUBSTANTIAL
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. FOR
THOSE WITH FELONY RECORDS.
MOVING ON WE THINK THAT THE
PROGRAM IS QUITE EXPENSIVE
RELATIVE TO OTHER RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION INTERVENTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE SAME ANNUAL
COST OF THE PROGRAM CCR COULD
INSTEAD PROVIDE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY WHICH IS AN
INTERVENTION THAT'S BEEN FOUND
ELSEWHERE TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
TO OF OVER FIVE THOUSAND INMATES
ANNUALLY.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
PROPOSED LARGE UP FRONT CAPITAL
OUTLAY INVESTMENT FOR A PROGRAM
THAT APPEARS TO BE UNLIKELY TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND HAS NOT BEEN
TESTED VIA PILOT.
I HAVE FURTHER MORE IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER ALL OF THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WOULD BE NEEDED GIVEN
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A
PROVIDED FIRM PLANS ON SEVERAL
OF THE DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND FINALLY WE NOTE THAT THERE
ARE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO TRAIN
THE TWENTY NINE PEARL E.
CONSERVATION CORPS MEMBERS THAT
DON'T REQUIRE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM.
SO WE RECOMMEND REJECTING AND TO
THE EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTED IN. REDUCING
RECIDIVISM I COULD REDIRECT SOME
OR ALL OF THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES TO. SUPPORT EVIDENCE
BASED REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
YEAH LISTA JONES SAWYER I'M.
YOU KNOW MOSTLY A PROGRAM AFTER
IN A.
HAPPEN OVER THE NEXT.
DECADE ON WITH PROP 47-57
PROBABLY WILL BE NEW.
AN UNTESTED NAM AND HOPING THAT
IT WILL BE NEW. AND UNTESTED
BECAUSE.
THAT'S TWO WAY WE NEED TO GO
BUT THE OTHER THING IS.
.
THE CONSERVATION CORPS WHEN I
WORKED WITH STEVE LOS ANGELES I
WAS THE LANDLORD WHEN THEY WERE
ON THEIR STILL ARE A MAIN STREET
AND I KNOW THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE. AND YOU PROBABLY GET SOME
DATA.
FROM THE CONVERSATION COR THEIR
SUCCESS.
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE. IN MY
DISTRICT AND CLEAN UP
NEIGHBORHOODS ALLEYS AND THINGS
THAT NATURE.
.
MY COUSIN WAS IN A CONSERVATION
CORPS.
AND JUST RECENTLY RETIRED FROM
THE C. LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AS TOM.
NINE ONE ONE OPERATOR.
AND SHE WOULD TELL YOU WHO WON
FOR CONSERVATION CORPS. OF.
DIRECTING HER IN A MORE POSITIVE
WAY.
SHE WOULD HAVE SPENT THE LAST.
OF THIRTY SIX YEARS OF HER LIFE
NAM.
WORKING FOUR LAPD AND MOST
PRODUCTIVE WAY.
AND SO I.
I DO BELIEVE IN IT I'VE HAD
SEVERAL BILLS THAT WILL ATTEST
TO IT.
I DO BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR
AND FINANCE EVERYBODY'S APPS
YOU'RE RIGHT WE DO NEED TO SET
UP SOME MEASURES.
SIR WE CAN TELL WHETHER NOT THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING. AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE NAM HELLFIRE LA WITH
THEM CONSERVATION CORPS TO
DEVELOP THOSE METRICS
IT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT. ON
NOT ONLY.
TO THIS COMMITTEE BUT ESPECIALLY
TO ME.
TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE RISK
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TTC OUR AND OTHERS AND WE
START MEASURING.
EFFECTIVENESS OF ALL THAT.
ON EXCITE WE PROBABLY NEED TO DO
A LOT OF FUN AND. ALSO BELIEVE
WE NEED TO PROBABLY GIVE EXTRA
MONEY SO WE HAVE TO HIRE PEOPLE
TO DO THE AUDITS BOGAN DO.
SOME ON TIME IN REAL TIME.
.
EVALUATION SEEK TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AS YOU GO ALONG.
.
SO I I.
I HOPE WE JUST DON'T ABANDON
THIS IDEA BECAUSE.
OF I DO BELIEVE THAT THE SKILL
SET THAT YOU GET. IN THIS TYPE
OF TRAINING.
NOT ONLY COULD LEAD YOU INTO.
BECOME A FIREFIGHTER BUT
PREVIOUS SKILL SET TO LEAD YOU
TO OTHER OCCUPATIONS NOT JUST.
I'M GOING INTO FIREFIGHTING OF.
BUT AT THE THE OLD CONCEPT OF.
BEING ABLE TO GET UP ON TIME
SHOW UP TO WORK ON TIME
SHINE YOUR SHOES.
GET DRESSED PUT UNIFORM ON SHOW
UP BE POLITE.
.
TAKE CONSTRUCTION.
THAT IS JUST AS VALUABLE.
AS ANYTHING ELSE AND I'VE SEEN
IT WITH THE CONSERVATION CORPS
MISSILES LIKE THAT WOULD BE THE
CORE OF THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE OF
WHETHER THEY'RE LOW RISK HIGH
RISK THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED.
THEY NEED THAT KIND OF A
TRAINING TO MAKE THEM A MORE
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS SO I.
I HOPE. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY.
A GROUP OF FINANCE AND HOPEFULLY
THAT WE. MOVE FORWARD TO COME
TOGETHER.
PUT IN THOSE MATRIX THAT I THINK
THEY'RE VERY VERY THAT IT'S
VALID.
ABSOLUTELY WE NEED TO TO HAVE
THOSE BECAUSE I THINK AT THE END
OF THE DAY WHEN YOU FINISH AFTER
ONE YEAR FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS.
I WILL BE HERE TEN YEARS FROM
NOW BUT SOMEBODY ELSE WILL BE
SITTING HERE AND THEY WILL LOOK
AT BILLS MATRIX AND SAID I'M
GLAD THEY PUT GO THEN. BECAUSE
NOW WE SEE THE VALUE OF IT AND
WE CAN QUANTIFY THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT.
HAVE NOT RECEIVED A BAITED THE
DELTA NUMBER YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
WE SAVED FAMILIES THAT WE KEPT
GATHER AND WE CAN ULTIMATELY
QUANTIFIED AND SO I. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT WE DON'T STOP
HERE THAT WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
MOVE FORWARD.
IN A PERMITS.
THANK YOU THOSE VALUES THAT YOU
ENUMERATED WOULD ALSO BE OF
VALUE I THINK IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
I THINK YOU'RE MAKING THE LA A
NERVOUS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
ADDING MORE.
TO.
A PROJECT LIKE THIS BUT IT BUT
I THINK.
WE KNOW HOW TO DO THE FIRE CAMPS
WE KNOW THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CDC ARE AND AND FIRE AND WE
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
OF THE SEAS AND WHAT.
WHAT GETS PROVIDED?
BUT I I THINK SOME OF THIS IS
IS.
WHICH I UNDERSTAND BANG FOR THE
BUCK HERE IF YOU WELL AND. HOW
MANY PEOPLE BEING SERVED HERE
WHICH OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY AT
RISK OR NOT? BECAUSE AS WE TRY
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHERE WE WANNA PUT I RAGS WHAT
BASKET AND HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
THE OVERALL SYSTEM?
FALLING BACK ON THINGS THAT WE
SORT OF KNOW IT SORT OF
UNDERSTANDS.
IT IS COMFORTING BUT MAYBE NOT
ANSWERING ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE NEED TO ANSWER AND THAT'S
KIND OF HOW I TO. KELLY OWES
COMMENTS HERE IS IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE BE REACHING.
HOW HOW EFFECTIVE THIS IS GONNA
BE VERSUS OTHER INVESTMENTS THAT
THAT WE COULD WE COULD BE MAKING
FOR ESPECIALLY HIGH RISK
POPULATIONS BECAUSE WE DON'T
ALWAYS DO A VERY GOOD JOB?
WITH A HIGH RISK POPULATIONS AND
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AS A
CDC ARE. TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
ACROSS THE BOARD TO START TO
MOVE PEOPLE AWAY FROM THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND LOOK FOR OTHER
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE.
GOOD FOR OUR COMMUNITIES BOTH
FROM PUBLIC SAFETY STANDPOINT
BUT ALSO FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RETURNING FROM THE PRISON SYSTEM
AND ENSURING THAT WE ARE PUTTING
THEM TO WORK TO GET IN THE HOUSE
PUTTING.
GETTING THAT GIVING THEM ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE THAT WE
CAN HAVE AND SO IT'S HARD
SOMETIMES TO LOOK AT A PROPOSAL
LIKE THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF ALL
THE THINGS BECAUSE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW. ALL OTHER
EFFECTS
AND IF WE COME UP WITH A BETTER
WAY OF WERE OF EVALUATING UP A
PROJECT LIKE THAT'S. HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE SERVING AS OPPOSED
UNDER PROGRAM LIKE THIS IN WHERE
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING OUR INVESTMENTS?
THAT SEE THE RESULT THAT WE
WOULD BE LOOKING FOR.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
INTERESTED IN WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN IN THIS CONTEXT.
SO AND THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT
HELLFIRE THE SEAS OR OR THAT.
WHAT THIS PROGRAM REPRESENTS I
THINK THAT IS THE PROBLEM? IT'S
HOW WE EVALUATE THIS ON THE
BIGGER PICTURE AND UNDERSTAND
THAT WHAT IT REPRESENTS TO US
AND THAT IT'S MOVING US IN IN
THE DIRECTION THAT WE ULTIMATELY
NEED TO GO ON THAT THOSE ARE
SORT OF THE NATURE OF THE.
BUT THE QUESTION.
NOW.
.
YOU SAID YOU HAD A WIDOW OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
THROUGH THE PROGRAM.
THOUSAND RELEASES FROM FAR THE
WHO HAD BEEN THROUGH THE FIRE
CAMP WHO WERE RELEASED IN THAT
SIX MONTH PERIOD YEAH SO ABOUT
THE. AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY DATA
ON THEM.
WITH REGARDS TO THEM GETTING
JOBS OR.
WE.
AND FATIGUE TO YOUR POINT INTO
INTIMATE MISTER SOUNDS POINT AS
WELL AND AND MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
WE WE BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE OF
THE DURATION OF THE PROGRAM THE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
THAT.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COMING OUT
WHO HAVE A PLACE TO GO WHO'D
BEEN IN THE PGA IN IN THE CHEESE
FIRE PROGRAM WHO HAVE A PLACE TO
GO STABLE HOUSING ALREADY HAVE A
JOB A PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
COMMIT TO AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
PROGRAM.
SO. WHAT WE'RE ANTICIPATING AT
LEAST ON THE PURL SIDE IS THAT
MANY OF THOSE WHO DO COMMIT TED
AYE EIGHTEENTH MONTH EIGHTEEN
MONTH PROGRAM ARE PROBABLY CAN
BE THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE?
CONCRETE HOUSING THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT THE SOUTHERN REGION
INITIALLY TO POPULATED FROM
THOUGH SOUTHERN COUNTIES.
THAT TENDS TO BE THE HIGHER
RISK AND OF THE END OF THE
SPIRIT THAT SPECTRUM BECAUSE
THEY'RE THERE.
HOMELESS OR THEIR CALLOUS
CHIRPING THINGS LIKE THAT.
ARM WE CAN GET JUST ABOUT ANY
SORT OF.
INFORMATION FROM THOSE THOUSAND
THAT THAT THAT LAUGHED NAM AS TO
HOW MANY LEFT IN OUR YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT IN STABLE HOUSING HOW
MANY GOT HIM WILL GOT EMPLOYMENT
WITHIN SIX MONTHS THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS WE CAN CERTAINLY DO THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THIS
PROCESS IT WOULD DIFFICULT TO GO
MUCH BEYOND THOSE NUMBERS THAT I
GOT YOU THERE.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
IF WE HAD.
SOME DATA WITH REGARD TO I MEAN
I THINK MOST OF US HAVE A SENSE
OF THAT IT. PROBABLY IS A
PROGRAM THAT WORKS WITHIN THAT
IS AS AS WAS JUST DON'T POINT
OUT WHERE THAT IT'S A PROGRAM
WITH THEM.
GREATEST AMOUNT OF BANG FOR THE
BUCK COULD NOT. IS IS WHAT
BECOMES THE ISSUE AND OBVIOUSLY
WITHOUT A WHOLE LOT OF DATA IT
BECOMES. EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
OUT DO THAT IT IN THE REPORT
THERE WAS ALSO SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND I KNOW YOU GAVE
US A LIST OF OTHER. RELATED
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH IS WHAT.
MISTER JONES SAWYER WAS MAKING
REFERENCE TO.
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING IS IT.
THE QUESTION BECOMES IS THERE
DEMAND I THINK THAT WAS THE
OTHER QUESTION IS THEIR DEMAND
FOR.
.
FOR FOLKS IN THIS FIELD LE WE
KNOW THAT.
ANY TIME THERE'S A. POSITIONS
OPEN IN CITIES PARTICULARLY FOR
FIREFIGHTERS LIST IS ENORMOUSLY
LONG. AND.
AND SO EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE A
FIREFIGHTER AND.
YOU KNOW AND AS A RESULT YOU
HAVE LOTS TO CHOOSE FROM.
AND IT'S A DIFFICULT PROCESS SO.
QUESTION IS WOULD BE SWEET FOLKS
BE.
HIGHLY VALUED OR EASY TO PLACE
OR WHATEVER ONES ONCE THEY'RE
FINISHED
SO THE.
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT THE
COMPETITION FOR FIREFIGHTING
JOBS.
AT ALL LEVELS.
AT WHETHER IT'S THE STATE FOR
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AROUND CALVET
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
COMPETITION. THE BAR IS HIGH TO
ACHIEVE THAT BECAUSE OF THAT
AND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BEEN VERY LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT WITH WHAT'S TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE.
IT'S REALLY THE ONUS THOUGH IS
ON THE PARTICIPANT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE WILL PROVIDE THE
TOOLS
FOR THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL BUT
WHEN THEY LEAVE THIS EIGHTEEN
MONTH PROGRAM. THEY'VE GOT TO
INTERVIEW THEY'VE GOT TO EXCEL
ABOVE AND BEYOND.
THERE THEIR COMPETITION TO BE
SUCCESSFUL FOR THESE JOBS THE
ART AUTOMATIC GOING TO BE GIVEN.
OF THESE JOB OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE INTERIM I THINK IT WAS
PROVIDED YES THERE'S MANY MANY
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY
CAN BE WORKING ON. ALONG THE WAY
AS THEY COMPETE FOR FIREFIGHTING
JOBS ARE EVEN BEGIN FIREFIGHTING
JOBS WITH THE FOREST SERVICE AND
MANY OTHER A SEASONAL AND
PERMANENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO GAIN
EXPERIENCE.
WHILE THE INTERVIEW.
ALRIGHT.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC.
OKAY THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD OVER
I THINK IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT SOME OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE PLEASE GET THEM TO
US SO WE CAN GET THEM BACK TO
YOU. BEFORE YOU MAKE A FINAL
DECISION ON THIS ITEM OF THIS
ITEM WILL BE HELD OVER OPEN AS
WELL AS THE OTHERS UP FIFTEEN
ITEMS THAT WE'VE DEALT WITH. SO
WE'VE DONE ONE TO SIXTEEN IN
ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCHAND WE ARE ADJOURNED.
BACK TO THE FLOOR